le 6 avril des dizaines de tracteurs
défilent dans les rues de bourges
ils viennent de toute la région pour
refuser la perte potentielle car rien
n'est encore tranché de primes
européennes revenant aux zones agricoles
intermédiaire la région centrale de loi
à des zones à faible potentiel dit zone
intermédiaire et oui l agriculture est
très impacté et les malades
elle souffre et donc nous ne voulons
plus d'une pac pénalisante
six semaines plus tard le patron
régional de la fnsea a retrouvé son
exploitation de polyculture élevage
situé en plein soleil
la mobilisation des troupes dans la rue
qu'une actualité
mais le lobby du syndicat agricole se
poursuivent en coulisses le souhait
c'est que la nouvelle pâte 2023 2027
régime et elle n'a pour brise pas la
ferme de la région centre val de loire
quelques fois les productions comme les
autres syndicats agricoles la fnsea
préférerais des prix suffisamment
rémunérateurs afin de se passer de ces
primes européennes
elle appuie donc les initiatives de
bruxelles en vue d'un rapprochement des
coûts de production à travers toute
l'europe
mais en attendant l'éleveur laitier
solognot sait qu'il ne peut être
compétitifs sans les compensations de la
pac
oui on a besoin de ces accompagnements
et d'avoir une politique agricole
commune et en particulier donc avec les
différentes heures et fort la région
centre val de loire a été amputé et donc
on a perdu en dotation aux environs de
80 à 100 euros de l'hectare
alors la fnsea ne veut plus entendre
parler de réduction des aides
elle estime notamment que les mesures
environnementales de cette nouvelle pac
ne doivent pas constituer des outils
répressifs contre certaines productions
on est dans une parcelle de céréales moi
je suis fier d'avoir une céréale qui est
saine qui est productive et tout
arrêtons de stigmatiser voit
l'utilisation des défis taux des
pesticides
voilà on a diminué et le souhait des
agriculteurs cédant n'utiliser le moins
possible et donc c'est de
l'accompagnement pour arriver à bâtir
l'agriculture de demain tout en
n'oubliant pas de produire de
l'alimentation de l'alimentaire et faire
de l'économie la fnsea veut pouvoir
maintenir tout le tissu actuel
d'exploitation en cas de désaccord avec
la future réforme
elle n'hésitera pas à re mobiliser ses
troupes